omar abu saada wo leben sie das ist
kompliziert ich wohne in damaskus
aber da ich fürs theater arbeitet reise
ich viel und habe das gefühl zurzeit
nirgends zu wohnen aber eigentlich lebe
ich in damaskus
wenn ich eine arbeit beendet habe kehre
ich immer dorthin zurück leben in
damaskus
das ist leben im krieg
leben mit vollem risiko
leben zwischen gewalt und normalität
als regisseur zu arbeiten jedoch ist für
oman abu saada in der maske zu riskant
dort nicht zu arbeiten war auch meine
entscheidung
denn wenn ich dort arbeiten würde könnte
ich kein politisches problem
thematisieren könnte ich nicht erzählen
was in syrien zur zeit geschieht es sei
denn ich würde den blickwinkel des
regimes einnehmen und das will ich nicht
ich will das tun wovon ich überzeugt
fast alle seiner schauspieler sind aus
syrien geflüchtet weil sie gegen das
assad regime protestiert hatten und die
situation dann zu bedrohlich geworden
nun leben sie in kairo istanbul in
deutschland und fanden für diese arbeit
beim kunstfestival die saar in brüssel
wieder zusammen auch mohamed alabbar
lebt im exil
er schrieb das stück während ich wartete
das auf einer realen geschichte beruht
ein freund von uns wurde auf rätselhafte
weise zusammengeschlagen
man fand ihn auf dem hinterrad seines
autos bewusstlos dann lager im koma für
mehrere wochen
möglicherweise fanta übergriff von einem
checkpoint statt
aber niemand weiß genau was ihm in
dieser nacht zugestoßen ist
das ist nichts besonderes vergleich zu
dem was in syrien heutzutage geschieht
menschen sterben verzurrt und manchmal
ohne dass man weiß wer wen umgebracht
hat das kümmert niemand mehr weil man
sich inzwischen an diese nonstop
tragödien gewöhnt hat dass kummer als
metapher versuchung der patient time ist
im stück hellwach er singt und erzählt
vom leben als aktivist der syrischen
revolution
er beobachtet als unsichtbarer wie seine
familie wie seine freunde warten und
hoffen auf irgendeine form von
veränderung
das koma steht vor allem für die
vorstellung von warten oder über sein
eigenes schicksal bestimmen zu können
die selber bezahlen im moment einen
hohen preis aber sie können nicht
entscheiden wie ihre eigene zukunft
aussehen soll
die mehrheit der kämpfenden parteien
sind zuhörer aber sie haben keine
kontrolle über die entscheidung die sie
betreffen oman abu saada und muhammad al
assad erzählen was die menschen die in
damaskus leben bewegt szenen jenseits
der bilder die wir aus den medien kennen
menschen die trost suchen in ihrer
ausweglosigkeit die nicht wissen ob sie
flüchten oder bleiben sollen
menschen die mit dem trugbildern ihrer
gefühle kämpfen
szenen die auf keiner bühne in damaskus
gezeigt werden könnten bringt diese
arbeit um abu saada nicht in gefahr
die entscheidung in damaskus zu leben
bedeutet dass man sich in gefahr begibt
das tut jeder ich bin nicht speziell
viele menschen leben in damaskus 23
millionen
sie alle sind in gefahr in ihrem
täglichen trotzdem das risiko auf den
radar des regimes zu geraten bleibt
aber vielleicht braucht er die erfahrung
dieser stadt um theater machen zu können
um der welt zu berichten
aus dem innern von damaskus und es ist
meine stadt
da bin ich geboren da habe ich mein
ganzes leben lang gearbeitet zu leben
das ist mir wichtig mir würde die
balance vielen wenn ich nicht immer
wieder zurückkehren könnte
vielleicht fühle ich auch so etwas wie
schuld das was meiner stadt jetzt wieder
fehlt ich bin am teilnehmen obwohl ich
nur ein zeuge sein kann dessen was dort
passiert das tue ich